joining me here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line is one of the crucial
members of the green bay packers offense
and certainly of that backfield he has
been dynamite uh in his second year in
the national football league out of
boston college green bay packers running
back aj dillon here on the rich island
show how you doing sir
how you doing uh doing very well thank
you uh for having me i appreciate the
time absolutely i don't know how to
start with you
uh all right let's go right into the
overalls what the hell was that were you
not cold with the overalls after the
game you know let's just jump in
it was definitely cold out there i'm not
going to be that guy who's like oh the
cold's a mindset yeah but after you've
been out there for a long enough time it
all does kind of feel the same and at
that point
uh you know i had to represent i'm
always talking about uh being a
uh
wisconsinite or a scan as some would
call it so it was only right i go out
there and represent that's a choice i'll
be honest with you don't you think
that's a choice what you did so so walk
me through the process did you know
you know i guess i know you went out on
on the post game show uh after beating
the vikings right here on peacock as a
matter of fact uh in your overalls would
they just hang in there you're like
screw it i'll just run out there in this
right now
walk me through the process it's
actually it's actually what i wore uh
pregame oh i wore it uh war walking in
the locker room you know just kind of i
really thought they embodied that work
pale mentality i just kind of wanted
everybody was talking about you know
it's gonna be physical it's going to be
a gritty game and that's just kind of
you know the mentality i had so for
really it was for the mentality for me
just kind of getting myself into that uh
idea
it was also funny and then you know i
was like hey
you started with it you got to finish
with it so here we go back outside in
the overalls well i mean in a way that's
that's the way you you finish it for the
green bay packers these days like you
are you seem to be in the role in in
certain ways of finisher has that been
discussed with you that you know
protecting leads finishing things off
rolling you downhill
getting first downs taking time off the
clock and putting the w on the board aj
dylan
it's definitely something i take a lot
of pride in you know when you get the
ball in your hand there's a running back
or honestly any position but that late
in the game and uh you kind of know the
situation the situations to you know
keep control the ball keep control of
the game uh it is a lot of
you know confidence knowing that your
teammates
you know obviously 12 and
the coaches and staff and everybody
believes that you know you can get the
job done do it at a high level so you
know i do look at those opportunities
where i'm out there closing as you say
or finishing
as a big sign of respect like they uh
you know know i can get the job done so
you know it's cool i'm just always
trying to figure out find my role and
help out the team as
much as possible and in terms of 12 and
finding your role in 12 obviously
referring to your quarterback in aaron
rodgers i kind of want to dive into this
a little bit with you aj dillon because
lost amongst all the hoopla about jordan
loves drafting
and what that meant if you will
uh was the fact that you were also
drafted and the conversation was why
take him too
that you know and i'm wondering how did
you take that conversation that was
being had nationally about your drafting
because you know there was another aaron
there too and it's just like well how
does that help out the 12 aaron by
taking a quarterback and then taking
somebody else at the running back
position when there's aaron jones there
how did you handle all that aj
um you know obviously i saw you know i
did see everything and you know i'm the
type of person like i do like read
through like the media and things that
people say
um but it like i i just like to read it
just because i like to see what's going
on but neither you know the good stuff
nor the bad stuff is ever anything that
gets me off of like my even keel
but i just like to see what people
saying you know i was uh you know i was
kind of like hey like you know i
understood it i understood it you know
to be honest
uh you know i hadn't been seen as much
as a pass catcher and then this offense
is a running back
you do have to be able to do play all
three phases of running back you need to
be able to catch and to be able to run
the ball obviously and you also need to
be able to protect
we got the greatest quarterback to know
ever play the game so you got to keep
him up
and um so just
yeah you know i understood it but you
know for me it was just another
challenge you know to come in here to
continue work and continue to you know
build my skills and like i said find
that role find where i can help out the
team and you know last year it was few
and far between but then when i did get
the opportunity to try to make the most
of it a lot on special teams and then
this year
as the season progressed you know what
my number has been called i've you know
really been trying to you know show up
as much as i can there's still a lot of
growth and still a lot of things i'm
trying to get better at but you know i'm
happy with the progress that's overall
progress is what i'm most proud of and
just continuing that well you should be
progress has been remarkable and so did
you get a
heads up a conversation that your number
was going to be called more or were you
just like realizing middle of the game
you know my number's getting called a
heck of a lot more
how did that work for you yeah i mean
yeah i mean there is i obviously you
know jamal is not here this year so last
year i'd be on aaron and jamal so there
was coming in this off season there was
kind of you know the notion that
you know i'd fill in that two role but
you know you can never assume anything i
mean we got a very talented running back
room uh obviously collin hill is hurt
right now but you know he was he's an
exceptional running back as well as
patrick taylor
exceptional guys and great to be around
so you know we got a lot of time in our
room and the good thing about it is you
know we all have that iron sharp entire
mentality we're really close in there
and uh it's really a brotherhood so it's
a great you know environment to work and
grow off of and aaron jones has been
like a big brother has taken me under
his wing since the second i got here
so he's been remark remarkable in uh in
all that growth process i was talking
about i love that kid man
and i i know you're another kid but uh
that's i'm referring to him uh even
though he might be a little bit more of
an og in a way um to you but aaron jones
i got to meet him he came in this studio
a couple of years ago
i just love his energy i love his story
i love his essence and then you know i i
mentioned his name 212 aaron rodgers
when he was on the show last year and he
gushed about him i'm wondering
how rogers has you know
has helped you with your role in growing
into it in your confidence level what
how has he been there on that front for
you as a teammate
uh i mean this stuff
uh you know it's honestly just really a
humbling experience to
kind of obviously as far as i've been
watching football for as long as i've
been watching football seriously aaron
rodgers has always been the nfl and i
would have been you know one of the best
to play the game so
i'm
now obviously having a chance to be on
the same team go out there to battle
with him and you know learn from him and
he's always giving me a little bit of
nuggets here and there things i can take
things i can work in my game like what
you got one uh you got one for me so
yeah i mean just just little things like
uh
in my routes uh just
kind of how to come out of them how to
break the certain way and uh you know
get my hands ready for the ball because
a lot of times on those check downs
uh you know if if you are going to get
the ball like it's going to be coming to
you by the time you're done going
through your reads and looking around
you got to be prepared
or running the ball just chasing my aim
points not trying to predetermine
everything just trusting it trusting
that the guys in front of you are going
to do
their job and so i think
you know obviously he's helped me a lot
with the x's and those and things but
the one thing i would say
overall is he's definitely helped me a
lot with my confidence
because there are a lot of things
a lot of things that i hadn't done at bc
that i'm asked to do now and
you know going out there and working
with him and you know every once in a
while you know when i do something you
know well or something he probably sees
that i've really been working at and you
know i get it right i get that little
nod and that's it you know it's not
anything crazy but it get a little nod
and for me that's like hey you know all
that hard work you know that stuff
you've been doing that studying you've
been doing there you go
you know you you got it done so
those little things and you know i try
to pay attention when he's talking to
receivers i try to take what he can
anything from there or anything from the
lineman just
anything but uh you know it's really
great to you know have 12 out there and
be around him and he's just a wealth of
knowledge
i don't understand aj because again you
said you pay attention to things that
are being said outside the the locker
room i thought he's supposed to be a
jerk and thus he's not the mvp aj i
thought that's uh supposed to be the
case i'm kind of confused with what
you're telling me right now yeah yeah
you know a lot of people hate greatness
man uh just what it is well i mean he
was talking about the off-season stuff
about the fans i mean again this is an
mvp voter we're saying he's not voting
for rogers how did that one sit in the
locker room i know rogers personally
responded but i'm just wondering how
that all sat
with you and your teammates
uh we didn't really talk about it you
know we just kind of focus on the the
task at hand that's going on obviously
this week we got detroit
um you know i'm sure everybody has their
own opinions but you know nobody
made any
we know what we know who 12 is we know
what he stands for and we know he's a
great leader and a great teammate and uh
we all love him and support him well
again i guess then the question is then
from that perspective um
is that the idea again this this this
voter for this is an actual voter for
the mvp
talking about the fact that he wasn't
available during
the
non-playing season when you're all going
through your otas and things of that
nature and then of course um what
happened during the playing season as
well missing that game and so on and so
forth with his
uh inoculation or what have you um
that that he doesn't makes him a poor
guy and teammate an mvp that's so so i'm
asking an actual teammate who's been
there on the ground about all that yeah
you know yeah no i mean you know
everybody has their own
you know kind of things that they go
through you know in the offseason things
like that but when 12 is here everybody
on this team will absolutely say he's a
phenomenal teammate and a phenomenal
leader
and there's nobody
in my mind that's more determined than
mvp
besides the numbers you know the things
he does the the little things that don't
show up in the stat book um you know
he's the best to do it
and uh you know it's crazy my two years
in the nfl
um he's been playing at such a high
level and it's so cool to see him be a
part of so yeah maybe it's you by the
way maybe it's you aj
honestly yeah yeah let's go let's go
with that
i've got aj dylan for a couple more
minutes here from the green bay packers
i've never really asked anybody this but
i've seen you know you work in your
photographs uh in in practice what is
your leg day like what's what's aj
dylan's leg day and and
what's that
it used to be a lot it used to be a lot
more intense uh you know going back to
high school and you know early college
when everybody's just trying to kind of
show off and lift as much weight as you
can you know i'd do what now for you
know would be looked at so poorly upon
and probably squat and deadlift and
lunge all on the same day and just try
to load up the bar but you know now it's
just about you they're obviously the
quads and the legs are big but yes you
got to get a moving fast got to get it
moving fast as well now i understand
that but i mean like what so what's the
what's the what's the quad right now oh
what's the quad size right now what do
we got
you know
we'll get some we'll start off with some
squats and then uh you know then we'll
get some movement and we'll get some
some side lunges some stuff like that
maybe some band work okay uh get some
flexibility in there and then roll them
out at the end make sure they're not too
tired i just cramped in the middle of
that sentence by the way
oh my gosh all right brockman go ahead
and ask him your question and send him
on down the line here chris brockman aj
so i know you're super into sports cards
i've seen you pop up in the ig lives on
a bunch of breaks what do you love about
the hobby who are you collecting other
than yourself and have you gotten anyone
else in the locker room involved
okay i'm gonna start with your last
question and then we're back but you
know so i have
uh obviously i got into the hobby this
off season
and you know i'm just kind of finishing
up what i was signing for panini um my
rookie deal and
uh
i got so i tried to get like jordan and
jordan love that is and you know i told
some of the running backs so aaron jones
just collected some cards i know that
for sure
um i know
like amari rogers i was telling him
about a couple weeks ago i'm like hey
like keep some of those ricky cars now i
don't just give them all out there but
um you know i love the hobby i love
uh just kind of the the fandom of it i
love i'm a big collector and i like uh
kind of collecting that memorabilia and
for me what makes it really cool is
you know now that i am a player just
being able to interact with everybody um
i do live breaks um i'll go
on the loop after so in the off season
i'll be doing a lot more obviously it's
hard to do in the season but i'll get a
bunch of boxes of cards and i'll rip
them open and i'll send them out to fans
myself and get the shipping labels and
all that but it's just so cool to i love
to interact with the fans as much as i
can and you know that's something that
obviously i know football i know the
cards and i know how much it means to
you know obviously the people on the
other end because i collect myself yeah
what's the biggest uh one you've pulled
in a break what do you got
uh so i got in a break i mean for not
for myself but breaking four other
people i pulled some some one-on-ones we
pulled a 101 joe burrow rookie
uh last or like before this season um
a bunch of herbert cards there were oh
the best the best one i got it was a joe
burrow tua and the justin herbert it was
a booklet at a
i don't think it was national treasures
but it was something a book with all of
them with the jersey pass and i think it
was out of like
10. i think it was 10 out of 10 so ebay
101 so that one was awesome
i got some good ones people i collect uh
obviously justin herbert jordan love
uh ohtani yeah oh
man that's gotta be good
do you have an aaron rodgers rookie card
how much is that one
what do you got i i don't have any
i have some and you know i'm working up
the the courage to ask him
do it here do it here let's do it use
this moment to ask him right i mean
let's do it let's do it bring the brain
in the locker room hey can you no no no
right here we will you know it gets
posted it gets clanked around see it
he'll see it you know we follow each
other on twitter i mean so so you yeah
like
you want him to sign the rookie card
right clearly right yeah at some point
you know i am i'm a big collector so
i've had like uh randall cobb sign some
and i'm not selling them i just hold
them i keep them
and uh you know at some point you know i
don't want to seem too much like a fan
girl now but uh aj here's when we do it
here's when we'd we aj here's when we do
it you score the next touchdown to like
win a playoff game or something like
that knock on wood for you in the middle
of the celebration you said hey would
you mind signing my aaron rodgers rookie
card like right there in the here what
because what you gonna say no to you you
just scored for him and the team
he will never say no i'll just i'll just
hide it under the goal post
something like honestly you have to wait
for the moment where he would never he
will he would never turn you down anyway
but i think
it's all about the moment yeah
yeah you got to pick your spot bigger
spot you've been doing that very well
lately i'll be very honest with you uh
so you did with the overalls uh hey aj
dillon thanks for the call let's do this
more often i really appreciate it and
good luck absolutely thank you so much
appreciate your time and also uh joan
did tell me to say hello oh you tell him
right back tell him right tell him right
back showtime he's one of my favorites
thanks for the call aj dylan at aj dylan
7 on twitter aj dillon2 on instagram
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here